I heard you say that you've been waiting
your entire life for for this got this
Godzilla film why was now the right time
for you and this group of incredible
people well now is the right time
because we had the rights so but now
I've been a Godzilla fan my whole since
I was a little kid and we wanted to
bring kind of a fresh perspective to
that and we were very fortunate to to
you know to come across Gareth Edwards
and if somebody would have said to me a
long time ago like look not only you get
to make a Godzilla movie but you'll have
this fantastic young director and you'll
have a cast that it could easily be
doing Shakespeare here in London versus
a Godzilla movie that that would be I
would be really excited about that well
specifically was about Gareth will
pretend he's not here just for us it was
a real attraction for you for him to be
part of this though I saw his movie
monsters and I was astounded at what he
did you know for such little money but
you could tell there was a real talent
behind the camera and so I asked to meet
him he came in and we spent some time
together
I was very very impressed and then we
gave him some resources to make previz
and some other things and many of the
shots that you see in the movie are
directly you know from the previs and we
just he's the only director we ever
talked to you about it mr. Cranston
morning good morning and the script what
was it you said that the script kind of
blew your mind what was it about the
script that really kind of captured your
imagination I think at first I was
thinking that this was going to be just
a monster movie and it really isn't and
the thing that nice did for me as far as
wanting to be a part of it was that it
has a very strong character driven
narrative to it
husband wife father's sudden
multi-generational and I thought that
was very clever and I've always thought
why not why can't you meld those
because you have the great epic iconic
battles with monsters in the monster
movie and and then you also have this
group of people that you follow and care
about and root for and you can have it
all and it dovetails very nicely into
this movie ahran and wanted you not bad
dads to have on screen as well as pretty
good dad to have and I wanted to ask you
about Ford and what qualities about the
character you really liked ya know I
mean for me it was the real challenge
there I was playing the lieutenant in
the Navy you know playing that sort of
America American military guy as role
ahem played before so I was really
intrigued into kind of doing that and
but yeah I liked you know I liked the
fact that he was a father and a husband
and and it had a real strong family
element to it and that you know became a
fight for survival or something you know
he had to almost just try and get
through in order to reach his family and
just have that moment together you know
yeah hi Lizzie mornin mornin and she's a
really determined character I like her a
lot she kind of doesn't really let
anything stand in her way
really Kukui yeah I think I it was it
was fun to play a mother who's
responsible for her own like emotions
and actions because of a child
witnessing it and so having that you
know trying to figure out how to go
through things that are scary but not
not let on yeah yeah you did that really
well you kind of see you know you can
almost trying to hide that from from
your child that kind of really relates
to that watching to myself and guardeth
morning sir how are you the morning
after your premiere I feel like it was a
wedding or something that's a good size
just feel like a wedding but the bride
didn't show up or something
so this embarrassing moment now it's
like yeah she left me and we had from
from Thomas that you know even before
you'd kind of signed on to do the film
you had a really clear idea in your head
about what you wanted to do and achieve
with this film yeah I mean there's loads
of different I mean that's one of the
reasons I think gods that has stood the
test of time is there's so many
different ways we could have gone with
this film there's kind of this infinite
canvas and it took his a year-and-a-half
of playing around to sort of land on the
story that we wanted to tell and it's I
think for me I grew up with those 70s
and 80s movies you know those early
Spielberg type things and it was before
the era of digital technology and
because they couldn't always show the
creature constantly they would like the
first half of the movie would be these
little glimpses and your sense of
anticipation like with films like alien
you know boy Ridley Scott and I just get
so many chills and goosebumps that I
felt like in modern cinema you know that
the temp is so easy to just throw
everything to the screen constantly that
we have sort of missed that style of
storytelling and so you know from day
one you know at constant references were
things like jaws and Close Encounters
and and sort of harken back to that that
era filmmaking even though we have
obviously you know these amazing tools
to just do Godzilla justice for the
first time Gareth
when filming monsters you famously
created a lot of quite a lot of the
special effects shots on your bedroom
computer or so we were led to believe
this time around was there any chance
for that kind of very personal DIY in
per Tata so megabucks Hollywood budget
deny that and and if not do you miss
that yeah I mean when we started I did
say like you know I'm gonna do can I do
just one one of the shots I'm just gonna
do one just for like old times sake
it'll be fun and they're like yeah yeah
yeah whatever go
and after the first week it was really
clear there was no way that was gonna
happen like you don't even get a spare
five minutes making a film but I mean
the beauty of it is that I was
surrounded with the best of the best
like the visual effects supervisor
gymraeg al he did Lord of the Rings we
also had John Dykstra who did the
original Star Wars movie and so you're
working with like my heroes you know
genuine heroes of mine and so handing
that's handing your baby over to people
who can look after it way better than
you can is an easy thing it wasn't that
difficult to give up do I miss being all
alone in a bedroom like yeah they were
sort of like I look you know look back
on monsters I'm probably my favorite
part of that process was doing the
effects from home because you know
you're on your own there's no stress and
stuff and like that making this film
it's genuinely the hardest thing I've
ever had to do in my life and but you
know the reward is things like last
night and when you get to show fans and
you sit and watch it and it it's kind of
like you know dreaming of the film is is
you know a lot of fun it's like where
you have you know you can just close
your eyes and imagine anything you want
to see and then showing the film is a
lot of fun because all but the middle
bit is like it feels like war question
well Godzilla who turns 60 this year so
congratulations to Godzilla he says
thank you he says Oh
is that your ringtone now you can you
can do anything you want as long as at
the end you go to get the movie ready
for this year and how did you deal with
the Japanese to use the monster and a
Hollywood version again Thomas Jordan
well you know in terms of Toho they were
great I mean we had a clear
understanding from the beginning with
them we looked at designs together but
from there you know they you know they
trusted us to to make the Godzilla movie
that we wanted to and they were there
were great partners so there wasn't a
lot of controversy on that front I'd
love to say we were really clever and we
were like you know what let's never make
this film ever until it's the 60th
anniversary because that would be
perfect
it just is I mean we just got lucky in
that sense and I didn't realize this but
Ken pointed it out that I'm gonna get it
a little bit wrong but you know they
have the Year of the Dragon the year of
their it's every 12 years it's repeats
and it's a five cycle thing and then
there's a rebirth and so 60 years in
Japan means the rebirth and so it's
highly appropriate it's a but I'd love
to we totally planned it that way it was
always I was actually offered the job
when I was 21 but we were like no let's
do this properly this is a question for
Gareth but I'd also like to know what
Elizabeth thinks I thought this was a
really great film I'm going to start by
saying that and I really enjoyed it but
I just wonder if there's a tradition
with films like this that the female
characters have to be kind of always
supporting characters I thought it was
with your grades and your the emotional
center of the film but we've got three
women a wife who gets killed off in five
minutes a wife who's sitting at home
when did waiting for a husband to get
back and Sally Hawkins is so much of an
add-on that you literally have her
standing three paces behind Kim in every
shot is that a commercial decision
because men go to these films Lizzie
I mean I guess our story at least for me
Ford needs a counterpart and in a way so
that he you know dude I think his
journey and correct me if I'm wrong has
to do with trying to figure out things
with his father in order for him to
become a better father and if you need
to follow one character from beginning
middle and end of this film it makes
sense for it to be a lieutenant and
someone who can navigate the US military
and I I do feel like I I got to serve
some sort of function by also being on
the grounds as a nurse instead of just I
don't know I worked with a little boy
made his little girl would've been
different but mmm I am I I didn't really
I didn't feel that for my character
Alise I mean this is probably probably a
good time to point out that Godzilla's
actually a female so in your face we we
at the last minute we changed from
Godzilla Queen of the monsters didn't
didn't sound too good but I know what
you're saying and I think I think at the
end of the day I mean we we we had a
version of a screenplay that was you
know had a heroine at the center of it
at one point and and you know you've got
to pick a hero and where you ended up
with a male and then everything supports
the hero in some way but I totally
understand what you're saying and like
my favorite film like this is it's like
alien and aliens and and I think there's
so many great examples and who knows if
there's if we get lucky and there's a
sequel or anything like that then very
much take on board what you said
godzilla is the king of the monsters and
i'll just wondering if you could have
him go up against any other movie
monster who would you pick and why who
would like to answer that one
I hate jars
so I feel like that would be an easy
swallow of a battle yeah good answer
next question can you pass the mic to
your watch which one is your favorite
I always harken back to the first one I
ever saw from 1954 and I was a huge
Godzilla fan as well in fact I had the
little figurines of Godzilla and I would
go into my mother's kitchen and get cups
and bowls and things and fill them with
dirt and glasses with dirt and I turned
him upside down to make molds to make my
own little city yeah and then my
Godzilla would come through and crash
through the whole thing I just loved it
so that was but I remember the Raymond
Burr version of it you know when they
inserted him in the end of the Japanese
movie and later on when I realized how
they actually came about doing that I
thought that was very clever so it by
doing that though it made it a universal
appeal to it and so it wasn't just in in
in the Japanese market but it created
fervor throughout the world there have
been some other films that have come
along that have been you know a measured
degree of success but I think I'm really
happy with this one because because of
the fact that you really we really took
the time to invest in in the characters
and in a way you could actually if you
just took the storyline of the
characters you could have like a
separate movie in and of itself it could
be that they're fighting to get back and
reunite and their family but to have
both I think makes the experience more
rewarding if I am one of the most
important I think is the crater the
monsters I would like to know how long
it took you to create your idea Godzilla
and if it is something that drives you
crazy I don't know if you see now they
cut Scylla in the biggest screen and say
oh maybe I'd like to change these or
that and the second thing is that for
the last 60 years
there is many version of Godzilla as a
character of superhero as monster who
tells you that you have to to create a
Casilla like a superhero I mean it was
your decision to create a Casilla - to
save their humanity or don't you feel
for a while that may be submerged there
and had to destroy everything sure I
mean I mean the great thing about
Godzilla a thing is if you had a load of
images of silhouettes of characters in
cinema history and you went around the
world and you showed people them and as
soon as someone went who's that or they
didn't recognize it you threw it away I
feel like the grand final would be
between Mickey Mouse and Godzilla like
that it's and I think what makes
something iconic is it has a very strong
silhouette and so when we designed him
we literally put the computer we put
settings on the computer so he didn't
have any texture he was pitch black like
jet black against pure whites and we
just kept rotating him and just pushing
and pulling and trying to get this
silhouette looking just right and it was
like a Rubik's Cube you'd get one side
good and then you turn it and you'd ruin
the other side but you couldn't cheat
and peel the stickers off like normal so
so we got it took nearly a year to get
it to get it to a place where we could
rotate it 360 degrees and go I don't
want to change anything and I genuinely
like you know I don't think you're
probably a filmmaker if you don't always
feel like I could have just done this
and I could have just done that but the
one thing that I do feel when I look at
godzilla it's like I don't really want
to change anything I feel like I'm very
happy with how we got him and the reason
he's an antihero
in the movie is because there are other
things that he confronts and it's I
couldn't imagine a virgin his film where
the audience is not rooting for Godzilla
so it's kind of inevitable once you have
another thing I think that was always
going to be the way guys were I liked
the film is that you've made a plausible
story it's not just the monster move
with this farm while going on I think
it's because it's rooted in reality
bizarrely and it's straight you play it
straight you don't play it for Laughs
and I wondered Thomas and and Gareth if
that was always the intention that the
world there were gonna be no gags in
this film thank you yeah we we sort of
had a set of rules going in that he was
gonna look like Godzilla that we
absolutely we didn't want to do the
campy version we wanted to imagine as
best we could what would happen if you
you know turned on the TV in Godzilla
had come ashore
what would the reactions being so forth
and and that really was a choice from
the very beginning and something that
you know from the very first
conversations with Gareth that that we
talked about and that he embraced no I
mean I think if the thing is is if this
really happened like I love to take
these sort of things seriously but if it
really happened if there really was a
giant monster they came out and did
these things it would be the most
horrific world-changing event ever and
and this is what we said you know that's
what Brian was talking about I think in
that it's it would be like World War two
or even worse and and and within that
like you know you've got such a range of
different films you can have Saving
Private Ryan and Casablanca and and we
wanted to do you know take it seriously
and have it be a very emotional
life-changing event and and I don't know
I just I think these things are most fun
for me when you really believe it and
you really get pulled into that world
and and there is sort of comedy within
the film but it's not I feel like the
important difference is that the
characters are not finding it funny like
the filmmaker can find things funny and
and show things that makes you chuckle
to yourself or something but the
characters they're actually going
through the events are having a very
traumatic time so they shouldn't be
doing like wisecracking one-line there's
bill and things like that but Godzilla
and nuke
energy has always been kind of a twin
concept how much how was it for you and
do you see it at the end as a kind of
you know boarding against all problems
with nuclear energy yeah I mean I think
the first thing you do on day one is you
sit down and say so what is it Godzilla
movie what is it what what is it about
and it's not a simple answer and what we
arrived out was that Godzilla represents
nature really and that what's going on
in our film is the other things in the
movie represented man's abusive nature
and it's just this whole idea that the
more we try and control nature the more
we try and you know think that we we can
somehow contain it it always backfires
and and and something goes wrong like
you know especially with nuclear power
and things like that and so this movie
is really about that that we we can't
control nature nature controls us and
when we landed on that we sort of tried
to amplify it as much as we could
through the movie you've now done films
which are very small and inventive and
now a big blockbuster do you have a game
plan for alternating between the two now
is that one you prefer just a very quick
supplementary question to Alan is there
any plans for kick-ass 3 yeah I mean the
thing is this right this is the honest
answer to that question is no there's no
kick ass trick now is that there's like
you do a personal film or whatever you
want to call that word but you do a
personal film and I'm lying if I'm
saying I don't want I want that film to
be as popular as possible like that's
the most important thing is pointless
exercise if you do something that's a
passion project and no one sees it like
what's the point in that
and if you do a commercial film or a
popular film you want to make it as
personal as possible you want to make it
as creative and as artistic and so
whichever end way end of the spectrum
you're coming at it yet you swap heading
for the same place and so I mean I don't
know what I'll end up happening next but
I'm always trying that like the goal is
to get to that sweet spot you know where
people really like the movie
and and you're proud of it I mean it's I
think anyone's lying if they're not
trying to combine the two really and
kick ass well I said I think you know
I'm not contracted to do three it but I
wasn't contracted or signed to do number
two either so you know we kind of came
to a certain point all together and so
you know I can't rule it out but you
know there's no plans right
how about kick-ass vs. Godzilla now
we're talking I was throwing it out
there
this is a film about Godzilla bits also
about very human stories I'm curious
Brian Aaron if you can talk a little bit
about working on this wonderfully
compelling father-son dynamic and for
Lizzie and Aaron obviously you're
playing husband and wife in this but
you're also playing brother and sister
in the New Avengers film and if it was
curious keeping it was difficult for you
at times keeping those kind of different
relationships separate Wow it's that
kind of movie my husband and wife you
feel like brother and sister so might
have been awkward the other way around
what about the father-son relationship
let's see it's easy to mean I am a
father so it's easy to roll into that
he's a father too so it's easy for that
relationship to take place you know it's
it when you when you sign on to do a
piece like this you really are looking
at the material you talked to the
director you agreed in it and then you
hope that when you get on the set that
you'll make a connection it's not
imperative that you do but the fact that
that we got along and like each other
just made it easier to to meld into that
relationship we have this kind of feuds
you know and I was just angry in more
time what I would be cracking jokes a
lot so and he he acted like my son I
would say something and he would roll
his eyes the general disrespect for the
elderly I've got a question from my
nine-year-old son hag who loved the film
by the way his question is if you to all
of you if you came home turned on the TV
and the that your local town was being
attacked by monsters what would be the
first thing you'd do good question I
would call my mother just make sure that
she was capable of exiting her own home
I'd make a sandwich and watch the play
unfold like a sporting event Chaves
maybe I'd call Brian and ask if I could
come over and have a sandwich we're all
gonna die anyway
HD okay all right I really can't follow
okay should we leave it there then let's
leave it there then oK you've spoken
about how it took nearly a year to
create the monster but once you arrived
at that image I read in the production
notes that you used Andy Serkis
to help can you explain how please
initially the motion capture was all
done by Bryan Cranston and after a few
test screenings it was we felt God there
was a little bit camp
Bob Fosse
jazz hands Godzilla that I wanna see ya
know Andy came on quite late in the day
not what you normally do and and the
reason being is it's it was all animated
by you know that the long painful way by
animators everything you saw in the film
was turned by visual effects companies
but Andy Serkis and his team came in
because basically you're trying to find
like performance you know and in the
fastest way to do it is to have an actor
and as we were coming through the crunch
time of all the post-production the
fastest resort was to get Andy in and he
did a you know handful of the shots
quite a few and and found the saw wall
of Godzilla and a lot of the shots that
the most soulful moments
Andy's performance as reference for the
animators but it was I mean I think
Andy's like he gets associated with
motion capture but he's a genius actor I
think and it's very clear when you look
at you look at the performance as he
does in motion capture you go oh my god
that's amazing that's amazing and then
you see the behind the scenes and you
see and then you go that would win an
Oscar you know I mean like and he's just
underrated I think I think and it was a
real it was a dream come true for me to
be able to work with him do your movies
are coming out this week I'm sorry yeah
I just I just learned that like a week
ago
and you're smiling at the
every newsstand cover of a popular
magazine saying Hollywood's new
sweetheart I would like to know what is
your perception of hitting the big time
what are your thoughts and feelings
about it
my perception hasn't changed probably in
the last two years I feel really lucky
that I get to work with awesome actors
right now the ensemble of this film is
is kind of unreal in an international
way and it feels cool tonight and get to
work with most of them it just feels
awesome that I could be in the same film
with them it's the same thing with
Avengers but yeah I don't know my life
is no my actual life is hasn't really
changed much except for the prospect of
getting better work you have a very long
list of credits film and TV credits but
it seems that it seems like a since
Breaking Bad your celebrity status has
reached new levels and my question is
how is your life and and career changed
since this enormous success I I was
dubbed the new darling of Hollywood just
like Elizabeth was
you know an actor really is only hoping
for opportunity and we've been very
fortunate on this dais to be able to to
have that come to us and and if that's
what stardom means then then I accept
that
you know that's that's what it means to
me that I can work on a greater level of
material and to be able to have more say
in in what we do
when you first start out as an actor if
your agent calls you and says they'd
like you to do you say yes before
they're finished with what project it
was because you need the job and so
that's why you know when you first start
out you have a lot of product on there
that you've done that you're not
particularly proud about but it
everything was a stepping stone to get
to an opportunity where you can then
have more control of your own destiny so
but the other thing is is that you know
for Breaking Bad or whatever movie
kick-ass or you you don't really know
how it's going to be received you do a
project in a bubble and you you like the
work you you like the people you're
working with and you hope for the best
and Breaking Bad became this you know
this larger-than-life mushroom cloud
that none of us could have anticipated
we're very grateful for it but it's
certainly not something that we were
working toward that becoming it it's
it's the public it's the fans that
create a classic film or television show
it's up to them to decide if it if it
weathers the test of time and so two
will be this version of our film you
know in time people will look back and
say that Godzilla of 2014 was fantastic
except for some a couple of the
direction you know they'll say
I'll say it was great thank you you want
to express frustration to working with
huge crews how did you overcome that
with this one and did you overcome it
very easily I know exactly what you're
on about
and thanks for pointing that out it was
when I was working in TV and I think the
thing the problem with TV is it's trying
to be a Hollywood movie or Hollywood's
quality of filmmaking but it hasn't got
the resources so when you get to do it
for real
and you literally have millions of
dollars and the best crew in the world
and it is insane I mean it is the thing
that I was most surprised about was you
know you do a small film there's five of
you and you kind of then do this massive
movie where there's 300 you think it's
gonna be this massive difference but you
have to at the end and then but in you
driving onto set and you literally as
the director they like you're in a
bubble and they drive you straight to
the camera and you don't meet anybody
you get out and all you speak to all day
long is the assistant director the
cameraman and the actors and you
literally like just know five people
kind of thing and the most embarrassing
thing is like a wrap parties because I
don't know anybody and and if there was
a quiz at the end of a shoot and there
and you smile at people every day and
they went what does he do I'd be like I
don't know stands near a light holds a
microphone like you just you just
protected and so I was kind of I was
kind of a could convince myself thank
God that I was making this intimate
movie with just a handful of people they
just happened to have 300 spectators
around the sides so that's how I got
through it
fine and film school document and in
here there's a film called Oracle's
written produced directed and
photographed by Gareth Edwards and on
there there's a quote oh we've got the
whole query says our aim is to show just
what is possible with a relatively small
amount of money and a little imagination
so how do you feel now you've moved on
from the relatively small amount of
money bit of the quote how's your
filmmaking philosophy changed
you know what's funny about that that
that film that no one's ever gonna see
is it was a monster movie and it was
1996 and it was I you know as a kid see
I mean seriously if you ask me I mean I
got thrown out of school I mean out of
class when I was 10 and I remember
storyboarding a little short film and I
always wanted to do this but it's kind
of a never expected it to happen like
this is just so surreal that if I think
about it for too long either start to
get emotional or I start to get the
shakes or something it's kind of it's
it's I kind of can't process it I can't
process like what's happened I mean do
you feel the same way because like
you've obviously always dreamed in like
really successful actors and now you're
here what's it feel like I'm sorry I
wasn't listening Gareth you mentioned
earlier about a sequel would you like to
do a sequel to the film and if so what
would you like to do in that sequel and
Erin and Elizabeth would you like to be
in that c-clone world you like your
characters to go if they were how
awkward is that it goes to Bryan
Cranston yeah come back to haunt every
we said i sat down with Thomas either
night and had a meal and we were just
celebrating the fact we'd finished the
movie and we're about to do all the
publicity and inevitably as you're
chatting sequel do we talk about it what
you wanted to say and we both agreed not
to jinx it and we said you know what
let's just let this play out let's see
how people react let's see how they
respond and you know if it all going
well may 17th we'll be having another
meal and we'll try and figure it out I
think it's kind of like just having a
baby and someone else asking you are you
going to have another yeah